لكن يا ترى في يقين حقيقي على الله بان
الامر كله لله وان ماحدش بياخد اكتر من
نصيبه وبيقبل نصيبه ولا يقاتل عليه يقاتل
من اجل
بلده لكن نصيبه ده بتاع ربنا وانا بقولها
لكم من قبل ما نبدا الكلام
خالص عشان دي دوله وكان مشكلتها في السنين
اللي فاتت ان
هم هزوا ثقه الناس فينا مش فيا انا في
نفسهم الناس ما كانتش مصدقه ان ممكن نعمل
طريق او كوبري واستقروا على نفسهم طريق
وكبري تخيلوا الناس استكترت طريق وكبري
قال لك ايه ده كتير كتير ايه يا راجل ده
لسه بدري
قوي لسه بدري قوي من العمل والجهد
والمصابره
اسمعوا لو كان
البنى التنميه والتقدم تمن الجوع
والحرمان اوعوا يا مصريين ما
تقدمو اوعوا يا مصريين تقولوا ناكل
احسن والله
العظيم والله العظيم والله العظيم لو كمن
تمن التقدم والازدهار للامه انها ما تاكلش
وما تشربش زي ما الناس بتاكل وتشرب
مناكلش وما تشربش يقوللك يقوللك انت بتقول
ايه يا عم هم بقى ماسكين الكلام ده اسمعوا
لو سمحتم ادوني فرصه اقول الكلمتين عشان
لسه برنامج طويل قوي يا
جماعه يا جماعه انتوا عايزين تقول لكم
مكان على الخريطه في دوله 5% منها ارض
سحره
95%
سحره م اسمعوا كلام لو سمحت من فضلكم احنا
بنتكلم ان المرا لا يصدق ويتحرى الصدق حتى
يكتب عند الله
صديق وان المرا ليكذب ويتحرى الكذب حتى
كذابا يعني هم بيتحرر
الكذب وهم عايزين يبقوا مكتوبين عند ربهم
كدابين كدابين مخر
مدمرين كل يوم بيعدي على شعب يتنكد عليه
والله حجم الاسم والظلم اللي بيتحمل
الاشرار فوق
خيالكم هم فاكرين العمليه ماشيه
كده